before we go here's one thing you can do
today to live a happier healthier more
productive life it's thanks to our
partnership with Gretchen Rubin and her
award-winning podcast happier
research shows about 40% of our behavior
is driven by habits a strategy called
pairing is an easy way to create good
habits you pair an activity you love
with one you want to make yourself do
for instance watch your favorite TV show
only when you were on the treadmill or
looks like the podcast you love while
folding laundry this can be a powerful
way to reinforce a good habit and once
you've done the tests together enough
times the good habit will be harder to
break bad now I don't fold laundry as my
wife will tell you I just throw it all
in the drawer I don't believe it but I
do listen the podcast for all other
chores and it does work I'll actually
look forward to doing the dishes because
I'll pair it with a podcast I like going
to the gym and then getting the donut
that's what works with me and I'm salad
with the ice cream do nothing that will
do it for us we'll see you tomorrow